Vìa nghe tây dời khiến của đất người mì hai thình táng công bông sữa liệu cho thấy
Châu đả lần đầu tiên vượt Mỹ về viện trở quân sự chỗ khai nè
Cái thứ thằng sau năm 2020, tính thực ký dung đồng phát tháng 2020,
đến cuối thằng sau năm 2020, tồng vinh trở quân sự của châu Âu,
bao gồm cả vương quân ăn đã tâm nguy phy năng tiêu ro,
tương đường khoảng 28 phy bài tí đô lắm Mỹ,
cao hơn tuần số 7 năm phải muốn tìi nâu của Mỹ,
trong tháng năm và thằng sau vừa qua,
cho ông khám cách thêm người phy năng tiêu ro về trở,
với gà mùn nửa giá chỉ đến từ các đồng bố sáng vụ khí,
chuẩy yếu với suy nghiệp của phòng chú hư vực.
Chú khi đó, Mỹ phy về các đồng số khẩu bố phí lấn chủ khuyên nè,
nhưng không được tính là phy n trở,
việu quân ăn phải tự chi trà.
Xin mấy ngày phà mánh sự dịch chuyển và trọng dựng bị vật chủ ông chủ hộ chựa khép,
đồng thời cho thấy các nước trở ông đang tăng cường đồng tư và năng lực của phòng nội khối,
để đã vẫn xa ăn tuy như cầu của khuyên nè.